so here we are again just uh having a
great time here and uh doing uh horrible
things to people as usual
[Music]
yes I will kill someone on film
hey everybody Matt from gun here I'm on
location in Los Angeles at the house and
moves we're gonna be filming some motion
capture for the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
we got a lot of work to do so let's get
to it
foreign
Massacre the film it was a lot of Terror
there's a lot of uncomfortableness in
the way the characters moved and the way
they felt so if you try to translate
that to a to a video game really the
motion capture is where it starts
so motion capture what many people don't
understand is different from performance
capture there's lots of different ways
to do video games performance capture
you get your body your face your voice
motion capture is you're just doing your
body
no every single ball you see on me is a
sensor the computer picks up so when I
do this we as actors get to see on
screen the animated character moving
that's the beauty of motion capture is
that you can set up an environment
anywhere you layer out the space and
then it's your play world
let's see here
it's not good yeah there you go and so
the energy that I get from the other
actors is what it I need because I have
to create everything else around me and
so the one thing that's true is you the
one thing that's true is me and then we
can live together in that reality that
we've created and that's the glory of
motion capture
thank you if you think about a basic
character the different states that you
go through if you're playing a game so
really you have the walk
or even a Crouch or have a Sprint and
then at any moment you could attack or
open a door or pick up an item so really
it's about trying to understand every
movement you want that what we have to
hammer
Hammer so you have 500 shots you have to
get which are multiple animations per
shot and then you try to book the enough
time to capture those and hope that you
get it done so really it's very
organized chaos I like that faster kind
of
really what we're looking for throughout
this whole entire session is do they
look like they would if they were in the
film really that's what we're trying to
capture and three two one action
other people that are doing motion
capture are a number of
very experienced motion capture actors
so that helps just knowing the process
because it's a whole different deal than
just shooting film I mean movie aside
you don't do it for this many hours at
least the same thing over and over
at least you're filming like a scene for
maybe an hour and then you're moving on
and then maybe it might be a happy scene
um this might be a little bit more
tougher I think what's been really
interesting about motion capture for me
is the specifics that you need
um in an acting piece if I was to just
do a slash I might feel it in the moment
I might get really prepared and just do
what feels right yeah you can do it it's
almost like dancing there's a
choreography to it
um dancers have to have that emotion but
they actually have to know where they're
going to be on the stage being a dancer
I think gives you a superpowers an actor
maybe actually that's a pretty good way
to put it where you can use your body in
and and know have have command of
certain things and know you can do
things and and or how to bring them to
life using those skills as a dancer to
to build character actor moments you
know recognizable things we want someone
that can move like Sally towards the end
of that film she can barely walk she can
barely run you can just feel the emotion
as you watch it it's uncomfortable so
when we look at movement in our game we
need to capture that so we needed actors
specifically actors in horror or close
to it that could give us what we were
looking for we decided this time to
bring in some
actors that are known for horror
even though they're not playing a
character that they necessarily played
they're just great actors now here's a
little bit of horror trivia this is why
uh I feel a little ashamed I never saw
the original Texas Chainsaw Massacre
watched it several times to really get
the essence of him roach in a weird way
and People Under the Stairs was very
similar to the idea that it was fun to
mess with the people in People Under the
Stairs to protect the little girl well
he was a good guy but a hitchhiker
enjoys messing with people to terrorize
them and then go back and you can never
play a bad guy there's no such thing as
being a bad guy you don't think you're a
bad guy all you think you're doing is
having fun it's just to you having fun
in your world means lives don't matter
invite me to your next birthday party
it's been really neat with you know Kane
and the guys from the game really
letting you cut loose physically which
again I've never really really done
because it's just not the parts smaller
you know boyish face men get
twitch witch and back to Idaho and and
you know when we're we're doing the
motion capture stuff about hitting
someone over the head with a broomstick
like okay well I'm I'm I'm old I'm not
going to take a big whack at it and you
know you calculate all those things what
creates that character you know the mood
the environment the age the muscle the
weight the and it's it's kind of
creating your own personal algorithm for
for everything that you're gonna do
a lot of people
um
underestimate how difficult it is to
play a character like Leatherface or
Jason or anything because they say well
he doesn't talk
and there's no facial expressions how
hard can it be and my point is that's
exactly why it is more difficult because
you don't have those tools
how do you look scary just by the way
you stand without making it look like
you're trying to look scary
point being with Leatherface I'm trying
to incorporate what I did in the past
partially because I did do a number of
scenes as Leatherface and also out of
respect to Gunner Hansen who was the
first Leatherface that's the iconic one
you know the first time you see the
character and he did so many amazing
things I'm trying to incorporate some of
his personality traits like a little bit
of a twitch and
you know even though you're never going
to see it I do what Gunner did as the
character a lot I licked my teeth
Gunner did that a lot it was
creepy as hell
they'll see the light before this is
over so [ __ ] is a new character so
she's not based on the movie which a lot
of the other characters are considering
how iconic all the other characters from
Texas Chainsaw are like you know how do
you make [ __ ] fit into the family and
be as exciting and as interesting like
on the outside she wants people to
really love her and like her so she can
be really sweet but then she has major
Anchorage
so just like you say the wrong thing and
she's just
flips a switch
[Laughter]
I'm gonna find out what you taste like
Johnny is a new character never been
before seen not in the Canon yet of
Texas Chainsaw Massacre he's the guy
you'll meet at the bar in town that'll
talk to the ladies get him feel very
comfortable and then bring him down to
the house
and then he turns into a not so nice guy
when the bad man takes over
playing a victim is pretty easy but it's
it really does a lot of damage to your
body and to your emotional state and I
feel like not a lot of people can get to
that vulnerable state
I take the victim work very seriously
because there's a lot of trauma a lot of
work to get into that mindset and also
ground yourself through the reality of
the characters and it's that
confrontation that lift and Rise of
energy where our hackles go up the hair
on the back of our neck and it's just
kind of tightening in living through the
eyes and really connecting with your
partners and they're so great they're
feeding all this wonderful energy and
it's just
mothering you it definitely helps that
sort of emotion come out of a video game
you know take a little bit of physical
wear and tear during the motion capture
because you need to do it a little bit
I've worked with him on on sets as
actors as like an actor so we've we've
had like some pretty brutal scenes
together but we've never I've never seen
Kane's side of like stunt coordinating
and I mean this is what he he does it's
like his bread and butter so I felt very
safe with him here and he's very
knowledgeable I mean Kane's just a
goofball in general so I love him so
much
I don't know you yeah okay with Kane as
a stone coordinator we're actually
getting the chance to get very physical
and very violent safely Kane has been
really good at just watching all of us
and making sure the movements are big
enough and believable enough and that
our whole you know our whole body is in
it even though you don't see a facial
expression you
you don't want somebody gets hit harder
you're doing your hand or your elbow I'm
doing this forearm okay yeah just pop
him yeah okay you gotta hit him so he
can react Kane yesterday was like you
know this is really good but Sean you
have to understand when you do the knife
slashes It's gotta look like you're
hitting him so you can go harder
and that's a weird thing because then
you've got to go to your stunt guy and
go are you cool yes I am cool go for it
don't worry and you know and then just
really letting loose and wailing on them
and trusting they have you know it's
cushion it's not going to hurt them none
of the weapons we're using are
necessarily real I mean I could
still
take one of those fake weapons and could
still kill you
and I may before this interview is done
so
when you come into it you go I think
this is going to work right you're a
little a little worried because you
never really know how it's going to
translate but here we are close to the
end and the performances that we've
gotten
it's incredible any time in which I can
live out both fantasies and nightmares
for the fans and for the people who are
going to be playing these games it is
such a sweet golden opportunity I'm a
huge Texas Chainsaw fan so
um to be able to create [ __ ] was like a
dream everyone here behind me and the
way they're working and putting this
thing together so much is going into it
and it's amazing it's just a really fun
group of people and man uh when you play
Never Have I Ever when you're not drunk
you get to know someone really well this
kind of stuff brings you together and I
think everybody's so badass for their
own individual like you know quality and
these producers this team here has been
fantastic we're joking we're having fun
it's amazing I get paid for this people
are gonna play
a character in a video game
that is actually me is just
mind-boggling to think about all the
characters all the animations all the
features
um kind of tie together and they pay
tribute and respect to the film well
that's what we're about is trying to
make sure that when you play our game it
looks and feels like the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
[Music]